- Le siège social du CN a beau
être situé sur la rue de la
Gauchetière à Montréal depuis
six décennies, la direction
de la plus grande compagni
de chemin de fer du Canada
n'a pas trouvé de francophone
pour siéger à son conseil
d'administration.
(tintements passage à niveau)
Le CN se défend, disant
qu'il s'agit d'un situation
temporaire.
Par voie de communiqué,
l'entreprise indique que :
- Je vais être honnête,
j'ai été époustouflé.
- Surpris, choqué,
Justin Trudeau s'attend
à ce que le CN réajuste
le tir rapidement.
- Je comprends à quel point
les gens sont frustrés, moi
aussi je ne suis. Alors, j'ai
demandé au ministre approprié
de s'assurer que la CN travail
rapidement pour rectifier
la situation.
MICHAEL ROUSSEAU, PDG Air Canada
- Je suis désolé...
- "D'autant plus difficile à
comprendre, dit le premier
ministre, alors qu'il y a
quelques semaines le PDG d'Air
Canada a dû s'expliquer devant
les comités permanents sur les
langues officielles pour avoir
prononcé un discours uniquement
en anglais devant des gens
d'affaires de Montréal.
YVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chef, Bloc québécois
- C'est dans la culture
d'Air Canada, c'est dans
la culture du Canadien National.
- "Mais le gouvernement ne
prêche pas par l'exemple", dit
le chef du Bloc québécois.
- Il faudra mettre tout en haut
de la liste des dénonciations
du manque de considération pour
les francophones, la gouverneure
générale du Canada et
la lieutenante-gouverneure
du Nouveau-Brunswick qui sont
des unilingues anglophones
ou qui ne parlent assurément
pas le français.
- Au-delà de la dénonciation,
la pression du monde
des affaires à plus de poids,
selon cet expert.
IVAN TCHOTOURIAN, prof., Faculté
de droit, Université Laval
- On peut penser à une pression
de la part des investisseurs,
de certains actionnaires qui
pourraient faire enten
leur voix, qui pourrait
éventuellement, également,
à l'assemblée annuelle faire
entendre leur mécontentement.
- En tout cas, le bureau
du premier ministre du Québec,
lui, a fait savoir
son mécontement et sembler r r .
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- On a parlé à la direction
du CN et, la semaine prochaine,
ils vont annoncer qu'ils vontnos
et francophone